just want to bring you that breaking
news we brought you a few moments ago
john barron mp has withdrawn his support
from the prime minister he's released a
statement he says the sugree report and
the metropolitan police investigations
paint a shameful pattern of misbehavior
during the pandemic as the rest of us
kept to the covered regulations those
responsible for setting the rules have a
special duty to adhere to them however
for me the most serious charge against
the prime minister is that of knowingly
misleading parliament given the scale of
rule breaking in number 10 i cannot
accept that the prime minister was
unaware
so
that's john barron saying um looking at
the report he cannot accept that the
prime minister did not know what was
happening in downing street and as a
result he concludes that the prime
minister misled parliament that's what
john barron mp has said and he's
withdrawn his support from the prime
minister however steve barkley was on
the program this morning um and he said
the uh prime minister has honour
does the pm i have honor
yes he does
does he tell lies no he doesn't